[Music]
well hello dear friends Welcome to our
program I'd like to know as you probably
most of you know this is a question and
answer program where you send us your
question questions and we do everything
possible to do the research to find an
answer that is satisfactory from the
Bible and the spirit of Prophecy uh if
you would like to send us your questions
you'll see the address on the screen TV
at sum tv.org once again
TVM
tv.org send us your questions uh they
might not be answered uh in the short
term because we receive many many
questions but we put them all in line be
sure that eventually we will answer your
questions I have with me my dear friend
and the CEO of our Spanish Channel at
sutv Pastor David salasa thank you for
being with us for this program thank you
Pastor Bor is always a privilege and an
honor to serve with you here in this
program praise the lord well uh we have
uh some very captivating questions today
and we want to get right into them but
before we do we want to do what we
always do and that is to ask the
spirit's Guidance the spirit who
inspired the scriptures to come and
explain it to us so would you pray for
us absolutely let us pray our gracious
Heavenly Father we come before you
knowing that you are the one that knows
all things and that you inspire your
word to teach us the truth to guide us
into the knowledge of the things that
pertain to our Salvation And so we thank
you Lord for allowing us to know it and
you have also promised that the Holy
Spirit it is going to be our teacher the
one that guides us into all truth and
brings to our mind the things that you
have said so Lord as we humbly ask today
for the Holy Spirit we thank you for
promising that to us and we ask that you
will be with us right now as we open
your word we pray in Jesus name amen
amen well what do we have on the docket
today today pastor we have a very
interesting question question one that
comes from our friend Sheila and she has
a question in regards to a parable and
actually a verse in the Bible so I'll
read that question for us today she says
good day I need some help in
understanding the below verse please I
know it pertains to the teaching of
Jesus and that of the Pharisees but I
still cannot get about the old garment
and the old wine skin thanks then she
sends us the quote found in Luke 5 36
to39 I'll read it it says then he spoke
a parable to them no one puts a piece
from a new garment on an old one
otherwise the new makes a tear and also
the piece that was taken out of the new
does not match the old and no one puts
new wine into old wine skins or else the
new wine will burst the wine skin and be
spilled and the wine skin will be ruined
but new wine must be put into new wine
skins and both are preserved and no one
having drunk all wine immediately
desires the new for he says the old is
better so here we have the question that
she has Pastor what can we say about
this you know the best explanation that
I found is in the book Desire of Ages
Pages 278 and
279 and um I think that I'll just go
ahead and read the entire statement
which explains with luxury of detail uh
what she is asking about okay uh so this
is on page as I mentioned Desire of Ages
279 nor could the principles of Christ
teaching be United with the forms of
phariseeism
so uh the principles of Christ teaching
is like the new wine and uh the old
forms of the Pharisees are the old
wine Christ was not to close up the
breach that had been made by the the
teachings of John he would make more
distinct the separation between the old
and the new Jesus further Illustrated
this fact saying and now comes the verse
no man putteth new wine into Old bottles
or else the new wine will burst the
bottles and be spilled and the bottles
Shall Perish the skin bottles which were
used as vessels to contain the new wine
after a Time became became dry and
brittle and were then worthless to serve
the purpose same purpose again mhm in
this familiar illustration Jesus
presented the condition of the Jewish
leaders priests and scribes and rulers
were fixed in a rut of Ceremonies and
traditions their hearts had become
contracted like the dried up win skins
to which he had compared them while they
remained satisfied with a legal religion
it was possible for them to become the
depositories of the Living Truth of
Heaven mhm they thought their own
righteousness all sufficient and did not
desire that a new element should be
brought into their religion the good
will of God to men they did not accept
as something apart from themselves they
connected it with their own Merit
because of their good works the faith
that works by love and purifies the soul
could find no place for Union with the
religion of the Pharisees made up of
Ceremonies and the injunctions of men
the effort to unite the teachings of
Jesus with the established religion
would be vain the vital truth of God
like fermenting wine would burst the old
decaying bottles of pharisaic tradition
wow so I think that answers the question
very very well uh you know the new wine
is is the are the teachings of Jesus the
fresh teachings of Jesus the old wine
Skins are the traditions of the
Pharisees which had grown old and so you
don't you could not merge the the
message of Jesus with the traditions of
the Pharisees right is basically what is
being said and as far as the Garment is
concerned uh you know if you have a
garment and you have rip in the Garment
and you put a patch on it eventually the
the Garment is going to rip particularly
the garments back in biblical times
right and so you don't put a patch on
the old garment in other words you don't
take the new a fresh truth that Jesus is
presenting and attach it to the old
traditions of the Pharisees so that's
really what uh this passage is talking
about and you know Pastor is interesting
that at the end crisis speaks that those
who have been drunk the old wine who
have been I guess involved in that
experience of paric you know idea
ideology they prefer that old wine
instead of receiving the words of Christ
now this is not to say that and this is
what something that I think a lot of
people have misused this explanation or
this passage to say that the Old
Testament or the law of God that's the
old wine and it's not nothing to do with
that it's specifically the traditions of
the Pharisees those things that were
human made those Traditions the Customs
that they had implemented that have
become really like you said like a old
religion all type of experience in their
yeah in in their Connection in their
rituals to God so that is what the Jesus
said is not compatible with what I'm
preaching but the Old Testament the law
of God all the teachings of the word the
whole word of the word of God the Bible
those are definitely compatible they are
part of God's word but not the paric
idea the new laws they added the
ceremonial things they had implemented
Jesus did not bring new
truth he presented the old truth in a
new light amen and uh and the Pharisees
of course their Traditions conflicted
with what Jesus taught because they had
a legal religion right whereas Christ
had a heart religion amen amen okay so I
hope that that answers the question uh
that was uh asked and uh what do we have
next the next question Pastor comes from
Victor and he's from Kenya and we thank
the Lord that people from Kenya are
watching our programs and also uh that
they find our programs as a blessing to
them he actually says this this as he
asked the question he has three
questions he has three questions for us
so the first thing he says is hello
ministers I am grateful about this
ministry and from here I have learned a
lot may God bless you my first question
will is will God have another church in
these last days since there are many
Believers leaving the church under the
general conference and opening 7day
Adventist churches with different names
based on the spirit of Prophecy that's
the first question what can we say about
this pastor this question specifically
well the bottom line is that God
established the Seventh Day Adventist
Church
Organization for one particular purpose
it's not an end in itself
the purpose was to plant Believers in
every nation of the world and for that
you need a structure you need organiz
you need to be organized in every
country of the world in order to gain
Believers in every area of the world so
Church organization is functional to
reaching the world with the end time
message of the 7 Aven a church now uh
this question asks whether uh you know
it's okay for to form another church uh
the fact is that that church is going to
be local in one place that church is not
going to have an organizational
structure to reach the entire world uh
and therefore it would be just a local
church or would only cover uh local uh
re regions and so uh also the Book of
Revelation tells us that there are seven
churches mhm uh the last one is the
Church of leoda which will return to the
condition of the Church of Philadelphia
so really you know establishing other
churches is kind of defeats the mission
uh uh of the Seventh Day Adventist
Church even though they might have the
same message they don't have the reach
uh that the 7th Day Adventist Church has
and so it is why the Lord has spoken
through the servant of the Lord that
even though the church may appear to
fall it will not because the movement
that God has established which includes
of course the organization aspect but is
really the movement that the Lord has
established as the seventh Church of
Revelation that the Lan church it's the
church is a movement that as you have so
eloquently said is organized to be able
to reach the world with one truth with
one set of doctrine that is found in the
word of God and um you know I think
there is enough evidence to know that
God is not going to establish new
organizations has is not behind this
idea of establishing new churches and I
think that a lot of these friends who
are maybe opening churches are maybe
doing it under um experience that may be
local to them and we cannot judge
specifically the cases of individual
churches but I think that in the big
picture people need to remember that God
has established one church and we are to
work side by side in proclaiming the
truth and bring people to this beautiful
you know church that the Lord has
established uh as a the last day
movement amen and that doesn't mean that
everything that's done in the church the
organization is correct right uh it
means however that we're supposed to be
loyal to the church we're supposed to
speak up when we see things that need to
be changed and need to be fixed uh the
problem is many times our members to
keep the peace which is not artificial
piece they say well you know let's not
uh let's not rebuke this this that is
happening in the church because it cause
Strife but Jesus said that he didn't
come to bring peace he came to bring a
sword and whenever the truth is embraced
there's division you know there cannot
be an artificial Unity saying well let's
just get along you know we might have
different doctrines but let's just get
along no Jesus was always inclusive when
it comes to people children women men
sick people rich people he was inclusive
of everyone right but it was never
inclusive of doctrines and practices and
so uh we need to stick with the church
and we to speak up when we see things
that need to be fixed and we need to do
it through the regular channels
absolutely and Pastor just to just to
add to this you know God has called us
that there needs to be a Revival and a
Reformation within God's church so it is
important that we keep that in mind and
we are called to as you said stand up
for the truth in love but in firmness to
know that we are not to compromise amen
Doctrine compromise the clear
instructions of the Lord so I think this
is important for the you know friends
who are experiencing maybe persecution
or or rejection by certain you know
areas of the world in that are doing
maybe not the right thing but ultimately
we have to stand firm in the truth and
be willing to uh you know defend What
the Lord Has call us defend amen all
right so next next question we have from
is still from Victor three the second
question is a very interesting question
according to Revelation 1:7 it says
there every eye will see him and even
those that pierce him is this
Resurrection uh happens if this
Resurrection happens then it will make
it three resurrections but Revelation 20
only tells us of two was this text
symbolic or there or there is another
Resurrection so he's questioning based
on that verse would there be a third
generation a third Resurrection rather
and uh will that be a third Resurrection
that's separately than the first and
second resurrection that is found in
Revelation 20 or is this a symbolic text
I think we have plenty to say about this
well uh we have discussed this
previously in the program there's going
to be a special Resurrection mhm right
before the second coming of Christ yes
before Jesus actually begins his second
coming all of those who died in the
faith of the third Angel's message are
going to resurrect and also all those
who pierced Jesus those who were
involved in his trial and crucifixtion
that did not repent of course right and
the greatest enemies of the faith
according to the spirit of Prophecy
right but that's not part of the two
general resurrections a resurrection of
the just or of Salvation and the
resurrection of damnation those are the
two so so-called big resurrections right
but the special Resurrection is an
exceptional Resurrection uh those who
Pierce Christ not only do we find that
in Revelation 1:7 we also find it in
Matthew
26:64 you know where cifas uh Jesus as
Kus you're going to see the son of man
coming on the Clouds Of Heaven with with
power right and so uh in Daniel chter 12
says many many who lie in the dust of
the Earth shall rise some to everlasting
life some to Everlasting damnation and
contempt well that can't be the
resurrection after the Millennium
absolutely because because it says some
first of all right and it also uh we
know that that the general resurrection
of the wicked is not at the second
coming the general resurrection of the
wicked is after the Millennium amen
pastor and and we can ask or let our
friend know that if he goes to early
writings page
285 uh it talks about there that special
resurrection and also in uh Last Day
Events page 275 it speaks of that uh
special resurrection that in a sense
could be part of the first resurrection
in a way you know like a previous as to
the main Resurrection but uh it as you
mentioned Pastor it's a is just a
special Resurrection very near or almost
when Christ comes second time and I
would recommend that um uh the this
person uh also referred to the book
great controversy page 635 to
643 I recommend that you go through that
chapter and look at the order of events
you know she says that the voice of God
will deliver the living Saints
absolutely she says at that time uh the
special Resurrection will take place MH
and then she says the sign of the son of
man is seen in heaven and Jesus begins
his second coming and when he's above
the Earth at the very end of his second
coming he's above the Earth then you
have the general resurrection of the
righteous and if you go to the chapter
the controversy ended you'll find that
the resurrection of the wicked is after
the Thousand Years amen so she makes it
very very clear that this
Resurrection you might include it with
the first resurrection like you
mentioned but it's an exceptional
resurrection of those who died in the
faith of the third Angel's message and
those who were involved in the
crucifixion of Christ which would
include um you know like the French
Revolution it says that uh that Christ
was crucified he was crucified through
the enemies of the faith so uh that
would be the answer I think to this
question amen absolutely um so let's
continue now with the next third
question from our friend Victor it says
uh that lastly a friend asked where did
the people that came was guarded against
came from well after killing AEL there
remained three people I told my friend I
was going to research it and here I am
so we think he I'm glad that our friend
Victor is using as part of his research
so what can we say about that Pastor
this question will what happened to the
you know how it was it possible that
Cain was protected or was told to be he
was going protected from other people if
there was only three living souls in the
sense of Adam Eve and Cain right but I
think that the Bible speaks of other
things and shows us clearly what
happened yeah well why don't you go
ahead and read the key verse there that
answers the question you know um there
there were only three to start
with but there were many others exactly
you can actually see in verse uh for
example
16 it says and Cain went out from the
presence of the Lord this is after the
Lord spoke to him and dwell in the Land
of Nod on the East of Eden and then it
says verse 17 and Cain knew his wife and
she conceived and be Enoch and he build
it a city and called the name of the
city after the name of his son Enoch now
this is not the same Enoch of course
just to make clear this is not the the
holy man of God who walk with the Lord
this is the son of Cain Enoch so here we
say that he says the Bible that he knew
his wife now that means that Adam and
Eve and I I believe it it mentions that
Adam and Eve had other children they
were not just you know set with Cain and
AEL they had other children and then
Seth even came in the picture which was
the third son men son that they have but
they had children women and daughters
rather and so obviously God knew that
they would have more children more
people and this is where he Mark Cain so
that no one would hurt him yeah and
Genesis 5 right uh Genesis chter 5 and
verse 4 tells us that after Adam and Eve
had
Seth that they had Sons and Daughters
yeah exactly God had told them to be
fruitful and multiply I don't think that
they were only going to have two
children you know they they had perfect
bodies they lived in an almost perfect
environment yeah uh so they had many
many sons and daughters right and those
Sons and Daughters had many sons and
daughters of theirs and so on and so uh
really it wasn't only uh Adam Eve and
Cain after Cain killed Abel right uh it
was actually uh the the Sons and
Daughters of Adam and Eve as well as
those who came after them and it's
interesting in uh in the genealogy that
you find in Genesis chapter 5 after each
person that is mentioned in the
genealogy it says and they had Sons and
Daughters yes so the ones in the
genealogy are only the representative
of a larger group of children that those
individuals in the genealogy had and so
I hope that that helps answer the
question yeah I believe this helps you
know uh answer the question because
obviously is a good question when
someone has is reading the Bible I know
sometimes we may find ourselves in
situations that we're like so how is it
possible but as we seen and you
mentioned Pastor the chapter 5 of
Genesis it speaks of the genealogy of
from Adam all the way till uh actually
Noah and speaks there that each
individual as you mentioned the
firstborn if you will right it was the
one that marked the beginning of that
family but it will continue with
daughters and sons and so same way Adam
as it mentions there had daughters and
sons and so the daughters of Adam became
the wife right you know a daughter
became the wife of Cain which was the
one that we read in in chapter four and
he had children Enoch was his first born
of the Cain and then the you know the
growth of his family continued the same
way with Seth and so that's how you had
this div this you know this open this um
tree of genology that that divided in
two sets one that was God's faithful
Believers from the genealogy of Seth and
those that are called The Children of
Men or the sons of men who were the sons
of Cain and eventually he became two
distinct groups yeah in fact in Genesis
chapter 4
you have the genealogy of Cain MH and in
chapter five you have the genealogy of
Seth right and the reason for Seth it
probably it would have been able yeah if
Cain hadn't killed him but uh but it was
Seth because um Eva explained in chapter
4 that God gave her another seed in
place of Abel whom Cain killed amen uh
so uh the answer to the question is uh
very very simple and that is that were
not there were not only three people
those three people multiplied and filled
the Earth and uh that's the reason why
uh you you have an answer to this
question is it possible also briefly
just the seconds we have left maybe that
the reason why you have the genealogy
first of Cain in um in you know in
chapter 4 is because he was the first
born in a sense even though he was
rejected because he chose to go in the
path against the Lord right and then you
have in chapter 5 the genealogy of Seth
as he was a substitute of that genealogy
that God had intended for came correct
so it's interesting okay well folks uh
time flies when you're having a good
time amen we really enjoy doing the
research to answer these questions we
want to thank you for joining us today
for I'd like to know we encourage you to
send us your questions we'll be do
everything possible to answer them may
God bless you hope to see you the next
time
[Music]